just the latest update i'm here at
rangiora airfield of just
uh thanks to the new royal new zealand
air force we've just
flown over lee's valley to inspect the
bridges
and the fords
it's fair to say there's substantial
challenges in there
we also had the opportunity to meet with
locals to hear
on the ground what's actually happening
there so it's good to be able to do that
so
we also had the opportunity to fly over
okupu and see
uh where some of the properties have
been compromised where the river's gone
so it's really good to have been able to
see it so we can gain a better
understanding our engineers were with us
and we now will give consideration to
the plan going forward and how we can
help both those communities get back on
their feet
remember uh we're here to help as the
council if you have any issues don't
feel free to be in touch oh 800 965 468
and let us know because we're here to
help challenging time for us all but
pleasantly we've got a much better day
today so
as again i'll say oh 800 965 468 if you
need help
you